el control de territorios productos
enfrentamientos entre bandas delictivas
de que la causa que motivó la explosión
de un vehículo bomba ocurrida en un
barrio de la ciudad de guayaquil la
madrugada de este domingo en el barrio
el cristo el consuelo de la ciudad
portuaria el ministro interior patricio
carrillo calificó este delito como una
declaración de guerra contra el estado
por parte de las organizaciones
delictivas hasta el momento las cifras
contabilizadas cinco personas fallecidas
y 20 heridos cifra que podría aumentar
según avanza las investigaciones en este
país es cierto que en este momento
existen informaciones preliminares por
parte de la policía nacional se ha
anunciado que para hoy en horas de la
tarde el ministro interior ofrecerá una
rueda de prensa y detalles de lo
ocurrido
por el momento patricio carrillo
ministro interior ha expresado en su
cuenta en la red social de 'twitter'
mercenarios en el crimen organizado que
han narcotizaba la economía hace mucho
tiempo ahora atacan con explosivos si no
nos unimos para enfrentarlos el precio
será aún más alto para la sociedad